happiest moment as an actor um I booked
a park named Queenie in the musical hunk
and it was my first like girly character
ever and it was my first solo songs and
all of this stuff and it was it was a
junior high performance and I just I
like bawled my eyes out because I was so
excited because I always played a bunch
of characters in each show and like
smaller parts and everything and I
remember that's the only part I wanted
and I wanted it so bad and it was my
first big success it like it for me it
was a tiny little like local play and I
I'd died that that I got the part that I
dropped to have like I was auditioning
for it I was in my theater school I
wanted this character and I got it and I
was excited because I hear you know
you're you're going through puberty you
don't know if you're pretty you're
really insecure and you're trying your
hardest to fit in in any way and I I got
to play the princess I got to play the
part that I wanted and that was the
first time that I had that and I went
home and told my dad and he was excited
on an oompa loompa you're not a tree
heatedly Queenie and I was exciting it's
exciting to know that you're like you
know I worked really hard and it was my
dream and it came true and it's exciting
as an actress for any any booking and
that was my first one that that's that's
what I wanted like I didn't want any
character more I wanted that one so yeah
I think that was my most exciting and
obviously you know I've had other job
since but it's always it's the first one
yeah Queeny Queeny
you